let's welcome mr. Rory Scovel
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow a lot of people are like should we
know him yeah that was you took the
longest time we've had we've had
presidents on the show that don't take
that much time yeah to get to their seat
I don't ever get this so I really wanted
to soak it up
I you know it's amazing you didn't have
a beard when you started to walk out
here no that's that feels good thank you
thank you we don't want to talk about
could you just be this the whole time I
just keep saying thank you and people
are like I like this guy Yeah right you
are there's so much to talk about I
haven't seen you in a while and always
you've been one of my favorite stand-up
comedians you're hilarious man
then out of the blue you get the role of
Amy Schumer's love interest yeah how'd
that happen
accomplished actor they begged begged me
to do it you guys know me I'm in
everything literally fell from the sky
somebody fell out they were like who's
available and very low priced basically
I love the way you sell yourself to a
crowd
and now it's time for them to know the
truth
so where's anyway were you working my
house I was with my daughter my wife was
gone to do a play for like two weeks and
I just put my daughter down for the
night and yeah I got an email from my
agent he was like read this script do
you want to do this tonight I'm also
like don't I just say yes am i at the
point where I read anything let's just
say yes yeah so you have automatic
you're at automatic yeah yeah so I'm
reading it and I've known ami through
stand-up for a long time and she at
texting me she's like it looks like
there's gonna happen I'm like I don't
even know what's going on I don't know
any of this and then three days later I
flew to New York and we started shooting
a film yeah I'm in a film yes you are
you know what's funny if it's not funny
but people love your performance and now
you're showing up they do they love your
performance and I didn't say that was a
funny part but now these comments come
out online yeah like this one this
website wrote this about you and I think
we have it here
Rory smoking leads a new generation of
sneaky sexy yeah leading man yeah you
know and when decider gets the word out
that means it's gossip a decided yeah
but my question is this seems like a
backhanded compliment oh yeah yeah when
it like I love that it it's like sneaky
sexy is like on the outside no way
but then we get to know him and we're
like maybe there's something to this guy
also leads a new generation of Sneaky's
I've done one leading romantic love
interest thing and suddenly he's leading
a generation of men who are like six out
of ten yeah that's our fearless leader
Europe where's our leader average
you